The Bachelor is back with Nick Viall
looking for love for the fourth time so
what can you expect well I'm like Nick
we've got you covered because ETonline
lauren zima was not afraid to put Nick
in hot seat I like someone who can keep
up with me and some challenge me isn't
afraid to call me out on some of my BS
which I'm sure there's something oh
really Nick well how about two years ago
when you out it bachelorette andi
dorfman on national TV if you weren't in
love with me I'm just not sure why like
why you made like a key item then last
year remember the Bachelorette runner-up
also got caught sleeping with Kaitlyn
Bristowe the Annika Beck I had to unhand
for you you slept with Angie and Galen
and will you go the distance and get
physical with women before the fantasy
suites as The Bachelor um probably not
yeah that didn't work out very well Wow
hope it's gonna be a sexy season but as
far as you know going around all the
bases we might pump the brakes on that a
little bit I want Nick right now right
now on the 21st season there are now
even more ladies to choose from 30 but
eight won't make it past the first rose
ceremony how would you react if any of
your ax your past women came back for
cameos or anything else oh that would be
interesting for better or worse i'm
going to be myself Nick teased he's
definitely found love but the 36 year
old software salesman stop shy of saying
if he's engaged what if you're still
single at the end of a fourth season
that's always possible listen I there's
no guarantees in this right what's your
biggest fear growing old getting away
it's bound to happen someday
you